THIS HAPPENED EARLIER IN THE
WEEK AND WE SAVED THIS JUST
FOR YOU. WE COULD HAVE DONE IT
YESTERDAY BUT I WANTED
YOUR EXPERT ANALYSIS
OF THE COMMENTS THAT
TOM BRADY
PROVIDED TO JAMES CORDEN
OF
THE LATE, LATE SHOW RIDING
AROUND IN A GOLF CART. HERE'S
THE CONVERSATION
THAT THEY HAD MET LITTLE BIT
OF A
A BUZZ
YESTERDAY MORNING.
DO YOU EVER THINK WHAT MORE AM
I GOING TO DO IN THE SPORT?
YOU KNOW. IT'S HARD TO WALK
AWAY FROM SOMETHING
THAT YOU KNOW YOU STILL FEEL
LIKE YOU CAN DO AND YOU
WANT TO DO SO IT'S NOT ABOUT
PROVING IT TO OTHERS
WRITE WHAT YOU CAN DO, IT'S
MORE ABOUT PROVING TO YOURSELF
AND I STILL FEEL LIKE EVEN
THOUGH
BE 44 THIS YEAR,
I STILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
STILL
PROVE IT TO MYSELF THAT I CAN
STILL DO IT 44 BECAUSE I
REALLY
WORKED
TO A POINT WHERE I CAN
STILL DO IT AT THE SAME.
THERE'S ONE THING BEING LIKE,
REALLY GOOD AT SOMETHING.
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE ABOUT
BEING THE GREATEST OF ALL
TIME.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU THINK ABOUT
ABOUT THAT? I DON'T REALLY
KNOW BECAUSE THEY DON'T NEVER.
YOU NEVER SIT AND THINK
WHAT I DO.
I'M THE BEST.
IT'S LIKE, SAYING,
YOU KNOW, WHAT DO YOU LIKE
BETTER STEAK FISH CHICKEN?
CHICKEN. I MEAN, EVERYTHING'S
GOOD. YEAH, YOU'RE DOING.
YES.
LOOK TWO THINGS SAID
THERE BY, TOM, BRADY,
FIRST, HE'S NO LONGER DOING IT
FOR OTHERS. HE'S DOING IT FOR
HIMSELF. HE'S NO LONGER TRYING
TO PROVE ANYONE WRONG. HE'S
TRYING TO PROVE TO HIMSELF
THAT HE CAN PLAY. AND THEN
ALSO, HE NEVER THINKS ABOUT
BEING THE BEST OF ALL TIME. I
SUBMIT THAT BOTH
ARE
ARE NOT A TRUE INDICATION OF
HOW HE ACTUALLY BELIEVES YOUR
THOUGHTS. OKAY. SO LET'S LET'S
BREAK IT DOWN. PIECE BY PIECE
I WOULD SAY THE PROVING
IT TO HIMSELF
PART
I BELIEVE
I BELIEVE THAT BECAUSE
LAST SEASON, HE WAS PROVING IT
TO EVERYONE ELSE, HE WAS
PROVING TO BILL BELICHICK. HE
WAS PROVING IT TO YOU KNOW
THE PATRIOTS ORGANIZATION. HE
WAS PROVING IT TO EVERYONE
THAT THOUGHT
TOM BRADY WAS IN DECLINE,
HERE HE IS
WHEN HE HAS SEVEN SUPER BOWL.
SO THAT PART, I KIND OF
BY THAT. THIS IS NOW
HE'S DONE IT ALL, YOU KNOW
WHAT I MEAN. HE'S IF HE
BEATS THE
PATRIOTS AND WHAT IS IT WEEK
FOR THIS YEAR, HE WILL HAVE
BEATEN EVERY SINGLE TEAM IN
THE NFL.
IT WILL HAVE WON. SEVEN SUPER
BOWLS, HE'S DONE
IT ALL.
THE LEGACY PART? YEAH,
I WOULD IMAGINE THAT HE
PROBABLY DOES LIKE TO BE
REFERRED AS THE GOAT,
BUT IT'S ALSO LIKE HE KIND OF
HAS THAT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ALMOST
UNASSAILABLE
SO HE'S IN A POSITION WHERE HE
CAN SORT OF SAY,
I DON'T THINK ABOUT THAT TYPE
OF STUFF, RIGHT?
NOW, I STILL THINK THAT HE
THINKS ABOUT IT AND I THINK HE
CONTINUES TO BE DRIVEN BY THE
FACT THAT IF YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD, HE WAS A SIXTH-ROUND
PICK IN
2000 AND HE ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED,
SLIGHT. HE'S AT THE POINT
WHERE IT'S SO BAKED INTO WHO
HE IS.
HE USES ANYTHING HE
CAN TO CONTINUE TO GET HIS
OLD ASS OUT OF BED
EVERY MORNING TO DO ALL THE
THINGS THAT HE NEEDS TO DO AND
TO REFRAIN FROM DOING THE
THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO DO MORE
OFTEN, YOU GET TO A POINT
WHERE YOU SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
LIFE'S TOO SHORT
TO NOT HAVE A HAMBURGER
LIFE'S TOO SHORT.
TONIGHT, HAVE A BEER. WHY AM I
DOING ALL THIS AVOCADO ICE
CREAM CRAP JUST SO I CAN KEEP
PLAYING FOOTBALL AT SOME
POINT. I WANT TO ENJOY MY
LIFE
SO
I REALLY DO THINK THAT
HE NEEDS THAT
EXTERNAL KICK
TO GET HIM TO CONTINUE TO LIVE
THE LIFE THAT HE'S BEEN LIVING
TO ALLOW HIM TO PLAY AS LONG
AS HE HAS
AND, LET'S BE HONEST HERE.
MIKE
THE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AT THE
TOP OF THEIR PROFESSION IN
SPORTS,
YOU KNOW, GO THROUGH THE WHOLE
LIST THEIR LEGITIMATE
PSYCHOPATHS. LIKE, THAT'S NOT
AND THAT'S NOT I'M NOT TRYING
TO
TAKE A KNOCK-ON TOM BRADY, HE
IS A COMPETITIVE PSYCHOPATH,
MICHAEL, JORDAN WAS THE SAME.
KOBE BRYANT LIKE, PEYTON
MANNING, YOU KNOW,
IF PEYTON MANNING'S
PREPARATION WAS LEGENDARY. SO
ALL THESE GUYS
THEY SPEND SO MUCH TIME.
AT THE TOP OF THEIR LIST OF
THE TOP OF THEIR PROFESSION
COMPETING
STUDYING
GETTING READY GETTING THEIR
BODIES READY. LEBRON JAMES
SAYS HE PUTS LIKE A MILLION
DOLLARS
INTO HIS BODY A YEAR. WHAT
THAT MILLION DOLLARS BUYS? I
DON'T KNOW. BUT START ASKING
SOME QUESTIONS
QUESTIONS MAYBE.
BULL.
BUT THE POINT IS
ALL THESE GUYS. THEY'RE NOT
NORMAL. THEY ARE NOT
IN ANY WAY, THEY'RE NOT JUST
LIKE US. THEY ARE THEY ARE
DRIVEN
BY
WANTING TO BE THE BEST.
THEIR COMPETITIVE NATURE IS
OFF THE CHARTS, THAT WOULD
MAKE ANY OF US. LIKE YOU
JUST SAID, MAYBE YOU WANT TO
HAVE A HAMBURGER? NO, THEY
DON'T, THEY REALLY DON'T. THEY
WANT TO WIN AT ALL
COSTS AND THAT COST IS
PROBABLY
REGULAR LIFE HAPPY YOU KNOW,
HAPPINESS AND HOW
IT LOOKS TOO.
TO US, WHETHER IT BE LIKE
SITTING DOWN
AND WATCHING TV AT NIGHT OR
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES OR
NOT. GOING TO THE GYM.
WHATEVER, HAPPINESS IS
THEY ARE ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF ALL OF THIS. THEY FIND
HAPPINESS IN RAISING
THE LOMBARDI TROPHY,
RAISING A TROPHY AT THE END OF
THE YEAR AND EVERYTHING
THEY DO.
AND IN THE
OF THAT
IF WE LOOKED AT IT AND LIKE,
WROTE IT DOWN LIKE
HOW YOU'RE NOT LIVING YOUR
LIFE MAN. WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
BUT THAT'S WHAT DRIVES THEM,
THAT'S WHAT MAKES ME CRAZY.
AND IT REALLY IS AMAZING
SIMS. AND I WERE TALKING ABOUT
THIS EARLIER IN THE WEEK,
THE PAYOFF,
THE CHANCE OF GETTING THAT
PAYOFF
IS SO
SLIM AND IT'S SO
DRIVEN BY FACTORS
OUT OF YOUR CONTROL,
NO MATTER HOW A FEW
HAMBURGERS YOU EAT, NO MATTER
HOW EARLY YOU GET UP, NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO
EVERY SEASON COMES DOWN TO A
HANDFUL OF
FLUTE PLAYS,
WHETHER OR NOT A GOOD DECISION
OR A BAD DECISION. IS MADE
A BAD CALL OF GOOD. CALL.
BOUNCED OF AN OBLONG
BALL THIS WAY.
THAT WAY,
I THINK WE MAY HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS LAST FRIDAY. NO
SIMPSON, I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IT, HOW DIFFERENTLY WE
WOULD VIEW, TOM BRADY'S,
2020 SEASON, IF THE
PACKERS ARE ABLE TO CAPITALIZE
ON THREE STRAIGHT
INTERCEPTIONS BY BRADY, WHEN
HE WAS HAVING A MELTDOWN IN
THE SECOND HALF OF THAT GAME
IN GREEN BAY, WHEN THE
BUCKS WERE UP, TWENTY EIGHT TO
TEN. SO YOU PUT ALL THAT
IN
FOR JUST THE CHANCE
TO BE IN THE VICINITY
OF ALL THE CRAZY STUFF THAT
HAS TO GO DOWN TO DECIDE WHO
THE CHAMPION IS IT JUST SHOWS
THE TRUE.
A DEDICATION TO THE POINT OF
OBSESSION,
AND
AGAIN, I DON'T THINK THAT
OBSESSION GETS FUELED
SIMPLY BY.
I WANT TO PROVE THIS TO
MYSELF,
I THINK IT'S SOME LEVEL IT HAS
TO BE DRIVEN BY
PEOPLE STILL DOUBT, ME PEOPLE
STILL
DON'T PROPERLY RESPECT ME,
FORMER QUARTERBACKS LIKE CHRIS
SIMMS, TOE STILL. RANKED ME
10TH IN THE LEAGUE.
ANYTHING HE CAN FIND
TO KEEP GOING BECAUSE IT
IS SUCH A NARROW
WINDOW THAT HE'S TRYING TO GET
THROUGH EVERY YEAR.
YEAH. AND AND
BUT I WHAT ABOUT THE GOAT TALK
THAT HE SAID I ACTUALLY KIND
OF BELIEVE HIM ON THAT ONE
BECAUSE
HE IS
LIKE THE GREATEST OF ALL TIME
QUARTERBACK RIGHT NOW. HE HAS
SEVEN SUPER BOWLS, I DON'T
KNOW. I DON'T THINK THAT WILL
EVER BE
TOP
SO UNTIL SOMEONE STARTS
SNIFFING AROUND IN HIS
NEIGHBORHOOD,
I DON'T THINK THAT HE REALLY
CARES
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT PEOPLE
WILL BE LIKE, WELL, HE'S GOT
SEVEN, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
SO,
LIKE, LET'S DO
IT. LET'S DO THIS.
EXAMPLE,
RIGHT. LAST DANCE COMES
OUT. LAST DANCE COMES OUT LAST
SUMMER. WHY IS IT COME OUT
BECAUSE
LEBRON JAMES IS STARTING
TO AT LEAST GET ON THE BLOCK
OF MICHAEL JORDAN. AND THAT'S
WHEN HE STARTS SAYING. I
CARE ABOUT THIS STUFF, I CARE
ABOUT THE LEGACY. I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE WHO I AM.
TOM BRADY RIGHT NOW DOESN'T
NEED TO REMIND PEOPLE OF WHO
HE IS
THAT
IF THE CONVERSATION IS OVER AS
OF RIGHT NOW, IN
20 YEARS,
HE WILL PROBABLY
CARE IF PATRICK
MAHOMES HAS
FOUR, FIVE, HE WILL PROBABLY
START CARRYING A LOT MORE
AND TRYING TO INSERT HIMSELF
BACK IN HIS CONVERSATION.
REMINDING EVERYONE. HEY I'M
TOM BRADY BUT AS IT STANDS
RIGHT NOW
HE HAS HE DOESN'T NEED
TO SAY I'M THE GREATEST OF ALL
TIME BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE WILL
SAY IT FOR
HIM.
THE ONLY WAY THAT I'M WILLING
TO ACCEPT
THAT, HE'S NOT THINKING THAT
HE'S THE GREATEST OF ALL TIME.
IS THAT IN HIS MIND, HE
STILL HAS MORE WORK TO DO.
SO NOW IS NOT THE TIME.
TO HAVE THOSE THOUGHTS
TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION.
I STILL HAVE MORE WORK
TO DO
THE BOOK ISN'T
FINISHED YET. SO
FORTH IF THAT'S WHAT HE WOULD
SAY.
I'D BE INCLINED TO BELIEVE IT
BUT THEN HE GOES INTO THIS.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE
WHAT DO YOU PREFER?
STEAK CHICKEN OR FISH AND
JAMES CORDEN IN HIS OWN
HILARIOUS, WAY CALLED HIM OUT
ON IT. OF COURSE, YOU'RE GOING
TO CHOOSE
STEAK OVER CHICKEN OR FISH.
SO, YOU KNOW, HE
KNOW, BRADY KNOWS. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO MAYBE THAT'S IT, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE HE KNOWS
HE JUST LIKE THAT'S MY POINT
ABOUT IT, RIGHT? THAT'S MY
POINT. HE KNOWS RIGHT NOW
IF
IF IN
15-20 YEARS
PATRICK MAHOMES ON HIS
BLOCK, HE IT WILL BE A
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION
ALTOGETHER. AND IT WILL BE
LIKE, HEY,
REMEMBER WHO I
AM AND DOING ALL THESE LIKE
INTERVIEWS AND EVERYTHING BUT
RIGHT NOW HE NEEDS.
AND EVERYONE ELSE DOES THE
LEGWORK FOR HIM WHEN IT COMES
TO DEBATE SHOWS AND
MEDIA LIKE IT
JUST KIND OF IT JUST HAPPENS,
RIGHT? LIKE
SEVEN, SEVEN SUPER BOWLS.
THAT'S I'VE ACTUALLY HAD A FEW
MOMENTS IN THE LAST WEEK WHERE
I SAID SEVEN I WAS LIKE WE IS
IT SEVEN? THAT'S CRAZY BECAUSE
IT IS KIND OF LIKE
IT'S AN INSURMOUNTABLE AMOUNT.
WE KNOW HOW HARD IT IS TO WIN
A SUPER BOWL. WE KNOW THAT
WHAT IT IS THAT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT TAKES TO GET TO THAT LEVEL.
AND DO
A SEVEN TIMES IS
LOIS.
THE FACT THAT HE'S TAKEN A
TEAM
THERE 10 TIMES AND THE
MARGINS WERE SO THIN,
THE
CLOSEST ONE.
ONE. WELL, NOW THIS
YEAR, THEY WERE ALL THREE
UNTIL THE RAMS WIN.
BY 10, BUT IT FELT
CLOSER THAN THAT, THIS YEAR
WAS A
BLOWOUT. ALTHOUGH, IT DIDN'T
FEEL LIKE A BLOCK, BECAUSE IT
ALWAYS FELT LIKE THE CHIEFS,
WE'RE GOING TO FIND A GAS
PEDAL AT SOME POINT, AND
WE'RE BACK INTO THE GAME,
BUT IT JUST SHOWS YOU HOW HARD
IT IS.
IT'S JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW
DIFFICULT YOU.
WORK AND YOU WORK AND YOU WORK
AND YOU CLIMB AND YOU GET TO
THE VERY TOP AND IT'S STILL
A HERCULEAN EFFORT TO
PLANT THE FLAG IN THE
SUMMIT AND HE JUST KEEPS
COMING BACK AND DOING IT.
THAT'S WHY I DON'T THINK
MAHOMES IS GOING TO CATCH HIM
LIKE MAHOMES. NO WANTS TO
I THINK HE'S TALENTED ENOUGH
TO DO IT BUT LOOK AT THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
NOW IF THEY WANT A COIN FLIP,
AND OVER TIME,
MAYBE THEY GET A CHANCE TO GO
FACE THE RAMS IN THE SUPER
BOWL. NO GUARANTEE THEY'RE
GOING TO WIN THAT GAME. THE
RAMS BEAT THE
CHIEFS IN THE REGULAR
SEASON
2019,
THEY'RE DOWN 10 POINTS
WITH SEVEN MINUTES LEFT.
IT'LL PULL A RABBIT OUT OF HIS
BUTT
TO WIN THAT GAME AGAINST THE
49ERS JUST TO GET ONE
AND THEN LAST YEAR BY THE TIME
THEY GOT TO THE SUPER BOWL,
THEY HAD NOTHING LEFT IN THE
TANK
PHYSICALLY TO MATCH UP WITH
THE BUCCANEERS AND IT WAS TOM
BRADY WHO'S BEEN THERE AND
DONE THAT NINE TIMES BEFORE,
WHICH I THINK WAS A MAJOR
FACTOR
BUT YOU KNOW, THREE YEARS OF
EXCELLENCE WITH ONE SUPER BOWL
TO SHOW FOR IT. YOU GOT PLENTY
OF WORK TO DO IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GET TO 7 AND YOU MAY HAVE
TO GET TO 8 BY THE TIME, IT'S
ALL SAID
AND DONE.
MAYBE NINE BY THE TIME
BRADY'S FINISHED, PLAYING IN
THE NFL.
LOOK AT AARON RODGERS, AARON
RODGERS, GOING TO. I MEAN,
THERE'S A, THERE'S A BETTER,
IT'S MORE LIKELY THAN NOT,
THAT AARON RODGERS WILL RETIRE
WITH ONE SUPER BOWL
AND HE WON IT VERY EARLY IN
HIS CAREER AND NEVER GOT
YOU KNOW
THAT SECONDS WHO NEVER GOT
BACK TO THE SUPER BOWL, RIGHT?
YEAH. RIGHT. SO
IT'S THAT HARD TO DO. THE
FOOTBALL IS, YOU KNOW, THE
ULTIMATE TEAM SPORT. IT'S
IT'S VERY, VERY HARD TO GET UP
UP TO THE TOP OF THAT.
YOU NEED A SPECIAL SEASON
AND YOU NEED LIKE YOU JUST
SAID, A LOT OF BREAKS TO
GO YOUR WAY THE BALL TO BOUNCE
YOUR WAY,
BECAUSE THAT'S, THAT REALLY IS
KIND OF WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO
YOU. THERE'S USUALLY
EVERY YEAR IN THE NFL SEASON,
THERE'S FOUR TO FIVE TEAMS
THAT ARE SUPER BOWL CALIBER
WORTHY. AND THEN IT'S KIND OF
COMES DOWN TO WHO'S WHO
PLAYS AT THE RIGHT TIME WHO'S
HEALTHY AT THE RIGHT TIME WHO
HAS A COUPLE BREAKS THAT GO
THEIR WAY AT THE RIGHT
TIME.
AS RELATES TO BRADY,
WHAT I MENTIONED EARLIER, HOW
DIFFERENTLY WE WOULD BE
THINKING OF HIM IF THE PACKERS
HAD
WON THE NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
AFTER BRADY'S MELTDOWN
IN THE SECOND HALF AND
THE ONE THING THAT I
KEEP AN EYE ON
BECAUSE YES BRADY WAS
PHENOMENAL LAST YEAR, YOU
CAN'T TAKE THAT AWAY FROM HIM,
BUT HE'S BEEN FOR
MAYBE THREE YEARS NOW
INTO THE
DUCK AND COVER PHASE OF HIS
CAREER FOR GOOD REASON. HE'S
TRYING TO PRESERVE HIS BODY
THAT IS ABOUT TO BE 44
YEARS OLD AS
AUGUST THE 3RD. HE SEES GUYS
COMING AT HIM WHO ARE HALF
HIS AGENT TWICE HIS SIZE?
SIZE AND HIS
MO IS
GET RID OF THE BALL AND HIT
THE DECK
BOTTOM LINE. SO
YOU KNOW,
WHEN DOES THAT
REACH A CRITICAL MASS?
WHERE HE CAN NO LONGER
GET RID OF THE BALL
BEFORE HE GETS BLOWN
UP AND
HOW MANY OF THOSE DOES IT TAKE
BEFORE
IT'S
IRREVOCABLY CHANGED?
TO HIM. I'M
I WAS TOLD THIS FOR YEARS AGO
SPEAKING OF
ONE OF THE FOUR.
FOR WATCH THE LEGS, NOT THE
ARM. THE ARM WILL BE FINE INTO
HIS 50S. IT'S THE LEGS. IT'S
THE LEGS WHEN HE CAN NO LONGER
GET AWAY FROM THE GUYS WHO
WERE TRYING TO
PUMMEL HIM AND HE STARTS
GETTING HIT, HE'S GOING TO GET
HURT AND HE'S GOING TO QUICKLY
SAY, I'M TOO OLD FOR THIS
CRAP
AND AND THAT'S THE THING I
KEEP WATCHING FOR.
AND LOOK AT, YOU KNOW, SOME OF
THE, THE MISCUES FROM THE
NFC CHAMPIONSHIP. IT'S DRIVEN
BY
THE WALLS ARE CLOSING IN AND
I'M GETTING RID OF THIS
FOOTBALL BEFORE I TAKE A BIG
HIT FROM SOMEBODY WHO
LITERALLY IS HALF
HALF MY AGE.
YEAH, AND YOU SAW IT,
YOU KNOW, THE BIG STAT, I KEPT
GOING TO LAST YEAR WAS WHEN
THE BUCKS HAD, YOU KNOW,
ALI MARKET WAS OUT FOR A
LITTLE BIT. THEY WERE A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT TEAM AND
THEY GOT BLOWN UP, YOU KNOW,
TOM BRADY WHO DIDN'T HAVE THE
TIME UP THE MIDDLE
AND HE WASN'T ABLE TO ELUDE
THE RUSH THAT YOU KNOW,
SUNDAY NIGHT GAME. WHEN THE
SAINTS BEAT THE BOX
BY A BILLION THAT HE WAS OUT
FOR THAT GAME. SO
THE OFFENSIVE LINE HOLDING
UP FOR THE BUCKS.
I IT HAS TO BE THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
SINGLE SEASON IS LONG AS TOM,
BRADY IS THERE.
ABSOLUTELY. AND UP THE MIDDLE
IS THE KEY. WE SAW THAT
TEMPLATE IN THE
2007 SEASON IN SUPER BOWL
42 WHEN THE PATRIOTS
ARE ON THE BRINK OF GOING 19
AND ON WHAT HAPPENED, THE
GIANTS PRESSURE UP THE MIDDLE,
THE JETS PRESSURE UP THE
MIDDLE AND THE 2010 DIVISIONAL
ROUND THE GIANTS, PRESSURE UP
THE MIDDLE AND SUPER BOWL 46.
THAT'S WHY. HEY OF ALL THE
TEAMS IN THE NFC.
I WORRY ABOUT
WASHINGTON FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF THE BUCCANEERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'VE GOT THE
GUYS
ON THE FRONT FOR AND IN THE
FRONT SEVEN, IF THEY GET
ANOTHER CRACK AT BRADY, IN A
SINGLE ELIMINATION.
ADDING, AND YOU COULD ARGUE,
THAT WAS ONE OF THE TOUGHEST
GAMES THEY HAD IN THE
POSTSEASON LAST YEAR, THE WILD
CARD ROUND
AND THE WASHINGTON OFFENSE
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH TO REALLY
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF WHAT THE
DEFENSE WAS ABLE TO DO. BUT
LOOK
HERE, NEWSFLASH, YOU AIN'T
GETTING ANY YOUNGER
AND THE LONGER HE KEEPS GOING
AND HE'S MADE IT VERY CLEAR.
HE'S GOT AT LEAST TWO MORE
YEARS IN HIM AT SOME POINT
FATHER TIME ALWAYS UNDEFEATED
IS GOING TO GET THE VICTORY
AND WE JUST
ASSUME THAT THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE INDEFINITELY,
JUST LIKE YOUR JACKET IS
IN DEFINITELY LOST. THERE WILL
BE A DEFINITE END
FOR TOM BRADY.
QUESTION IS, DOES HE DO IT ON
HIS OWN
OR IS THAT DECISION
FORCED UPON HIM BY
AN OPPONENT WHO
HITS HIM SO HARD THAT HE
JUST REALIZES, I GOTTA GO.
YEAH, BUT I'M DONE. I
RETIRED FROM
PREDICTING WHEN IT WAS OVER
FOR TOM, BRADY YEARS AGO
BECAUSE
THERE'S CERTAIN PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA WHO EVERY YEAR THEY
WERE LIKE, THIS IS IT THIS IS
OVER. THIS IS ONE YEAR
THEN WE'LL BE RIGHT.
YOU HAVE ONE YEAR THEY WILL BE
RIGHT BUT THEY WERE WRONG FOR
THE LAST SEVEN YEARS. SO
I DON'T KNOW.
JUST,
HE'S COMPLETELY BROKEN THE
RULES TO HOW LONG YOU CAN PLAY
THIS SPORT
AND AND OBVIOUSLY,
THE CHANGES IN THE
RULES FOR THE NFL
HAS HELPED HIM A LOT.
LIKE I DON'T THINK IF THIS
WAS
1999,
HE WOULDN'T BE PLAYING AS A
44 YEAR OLD BECAUSE YOU CAN
HIT THE QUARTERBACK A LOT
DIFFERENTLY. BUT NOW THE
GAME HAS CHANGED TO A POINT
WHERE YOU CAN SURVIVE
AN ENTIRE SEASON WITHOUT
TAKING THOSE PUNISHING BLOWS.
SO I DON'T KNOW. MIKE
LIKE IF
YOU TOLD ME, RIGHT.
NOW, PUT YOUR LIFE ON IT. TOM
BRADY'S, NOT GOING TO BE
PLAYING WHEN HE'S 50 YEARS
OLD, I WOULDN'T PUT MY
LIFE ON IT.
I WANTED IT. LOOK IT.
IT NO AS LONG AS HE CAN
CONTINUE TO FIND A WAY
TO GET RID OF THE FOOTBALL.
AND HE, AND IF HIS TEAM IS
WILLING TO TOLERATE THE
INTERCEPTIONS THAT WILL FLOW
FROM IT, AND THE BUCCANEERS
ARE
AS LONG AS HE CAN GET THEM,
CLOSE TO THE TOP OF THE
MOUNTAIN. I MEAN, THEY WENT
FROM
2002 TO
WITH TEAMS THAT WERE NOT
NEARLY
AS GOOD AS
WHAT THEY HAD LAST YEAR WITH
BRADY'S INFLUENCE AND THAT'S
THE THING, THE VALUE IS
HIS INFLUENCE. HIS ATTITUDE.
HOW HE RUBS OFF ON HIS
TEAM MATES, HOW HE GETS THEM,
TO FOCUS ON WHAT'S
IMPORTANT?
AND THEY LISTEN TO HIM, HE'S
GOT THE RINGS, HE'S GOT THE
CREDENTIALS, THEY'LL LISTEN TO
HIM. SO AS LONG AS HE CAN
PHYSICALLY DO IT,
I THINK HE WILL KEEP DOING IT
AND I CAN'T
RULE OUT HIM PLAYING UNTIL
HE'S 50. AND AGAIN,
I THINK HE'S
GONNA BE DRIVEN NOT BY PROVING
IT TO HIMSELF,
BUT BY, AND I THINK
WE'RE ALSO GETTING
THE POINT WHERE, AND I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. DONE IT FOR SO
LONG. WHAT THE HELL ELSE DOES
HE DO?
HE'S DONE FOR MORE THAN HALF
OF HIS LIFE.
WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO?
YOU DON'T NEED TO GO GET A
JOB. YOU GOT MORE MONEY THAN
YOU CAN EVER SPEND WHERE YOU
GOING TO GET YOUR FROM
FILMING.
WE'RE GOING TO GET YOU.
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE IN LIFE.
THAT THAT REWARDS YOU
WITH THIS BEAUTIFUL TROPHY
AT THE END OF EVERY YEAR.
AND, YOU KNOW, AN OBJECTIVE.
INDICATION OF WHAT YOU'VE
ACCOMPLISHED IN THE FORM OF A
PIECE OF JEWELRY THAT YOU
CAN PUT ON YOUR
HANDS AND WAIT.
WAVE AROUND. THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE THAT DOES THAT.
HOW DOES HE
REPLACE THAT F